so we all saw metal gear solid 5 the
division and uncharted 4 at e3 this year
but what about some of the awesome game
trailers that you may have missed out on
for one reason or another in a year that
will remember for the disappointing and
vague development trailers for mirror's
edge 2 and mass effect 4 here are my
picks for e3 trailers that really do
deserve the attention of your eyeballs
one more time
you
first up let's talk about ABS ooh whose
name essentially translates to the ocean
of wisdom the game from yet at the sony
press conference and is being delivered
by giant squid that's the name of the
developer not an actual squid it's the
first project from the studio founded by
the art director on flower and journey
and will be taking place for an ocean
adventure that draws upon the ideas of
the universal origin myth exists in
everyone's collective subconscious the
trailer has us exploring rich see life
through the third-person perspective of
a humanoid protagonist making their way
through the beautiful watery environment
if you were a fan of games like flower
and journey this could well be one to
look out for
orion the blind forest was one of my
favorite trailers and it's phuc to see
of tweets from gamers trying to keep
that feels inside them during the
Microsoft presa including this
contribution for me trying not to
embarrass myself in front of my
colleagues at a first glance the child
of light and brothers a tale of two sons
viben this one is pretty strong moon
studios are set to deliver the gorgeous
looking 2d platformer which on top of
its lovely visual aesthetic is said to
draw mechanical inspirations from the
classic Raymond and Metroid games the
trailer shows off critters that look
like they fell straight out of spirited
away and then they make friends and play
and then there are bad guys oh god I
can't watch this bit again
the amount of times this two-minute
trail has made me teary is too damn high
let's move on all right so fair enough
tomb raider was a huge game but the
trailer for its sequel rise of the Tomb
Raider was so tiny and jammed into the
Microsoft presa that you may have missed
it it only took a few flashes of a bow
and that damn climbing ax that only
works on ten percent of walls for most
of us to cotton on that we were seeing a
new tomb raider game the sequel seems to
be continuing Lara's origin story and
pushing the actual tomb raider ii bits
pretty hard which is awesome Lara's
badass and boat hurting the narrative
setup seems extremely cool and well
watch the trailer we become who I meant
to be
when Phil Spencer sorted out wearing a
limbo shirt telling everybody how much
he loved limbo it seemed like the start
of a segment pandering to indie devs but
then lo and behold came a brand new game
from limbo death play dead cold inside
as for what now seems typical of the
studio the spiritual successor to limbo
is very gloomy and focuses on puzzle
solving where you're encouraged to use
smarts instead of brawn the trailer
appropriately sparks curiosity to what's
on the inside and why our protagonist is
on the outside it's a 2.5 d platformer
that is using three-dimensional graphics
in a 2d play field and if you like limbo
it's a pretty strong possibility that
you'll be interested in inside you'll be
heading out to grab inside what it's out
you know what I mean watch the thing
last up is the one you've probably
already heard some whispers about it's a
game from a tiny form an indie studio
but the epicness of no man's sky has
attracted itself quite a bit of
attention even if you have seen this all
before hello games is upcoming sci-fi
game is well worth a second look and the
third the game's world is procedurally
generated so you'll enter it with a
whole new uncharted universe to explore
and catalogue technically this one came
out of the woodwork at the vgx awards
show last year but it's gorgeous trailer
during series pressler did a damn good
job of stealing the conference if not
the whole of e3 the world is beautiful
and bold and perhaps most excitingly
practically unlike anything you've seen
games do up so now gargantuan dinosaurs
rampage through vibrant forests and
great only battle it out see face all in
just a few minutes of trailer time
you'll probably want to keep an eye on
no man's sky if you know what scratch
that you'll straight up one to keep an
eye on no man's sky last week I told you
guys about my favorite crazy villains in
gay me and asked you to give me your
pics here do you reckon not get out the
evil dude park harkaman 1995 five said
vossen Glaros were definitely great
choices I would also have added Dutch
from red dead in there along with
general hemlock from dead rising 3 and
kefka from Final Fantasy to round out my
top 5 and I true colors said what if the
Joker from Batman Arkham Asylum my
favorite game in this series be an ideal
example of a villain who is batshit
crazy over on YouTube father Comstock
was also a popular choice for evil crazy
mofos that is it for me this week be
sure to let me know down in that comment
section where your favorite trailers
from e3 were this year and I'll see you
again next week
you